this video so this is i don't know who
this is but
okay it's look at this nukes oh he's
what [ __ ]
the dude's name is nuke squad i guess
nuke squad this is his
room in the five million dollar phase
nuke squad house
okay those that's a crazy ass sentence
my room in the five million dollar
phase nuke squad house
all right let's see it new squad
hey guys i'm just here hey yo what's up
that's tristan in the back
yeah so basically
this is my closet here's all my jerseys
these are my shoes for my cute little
feet oh my god don't fill my feet
they're not done today
anyway this is my trip feels so yummy
yummy i love you feels so yummy
it's i love i think lime is my favorite
flavor
but sometimes i drink the pewdiepie
flavor too
oh thank god i unplugged my straightener
before you guys came in here
anyways just for my face towels thank
you to my tier three subs for getting
this for me custom
is he a girl i don't know
no he's just one of those kids on tick
tock that raises his voice
just to be funny whatever yo what's up
dude how are you doing
his voice is crazy i swear to god this
guy's such a great voice actor like
honestly
shouldn't be gaming should be a voice
actor straight up also that's super
comfy i don't think i'm leaving anytime
soon
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right so he's talking
and there's more talk this is it man
this is just this is this is what five
million dollars buys you
nowadays it's because of inflation of a
dude
human man
them wanting a bean bag in there
yeah man we're just saving up for some
panel lights on the walls i think
that'll really
tie this whole thing the other day
beanbag is really going to set this
thing up
i i just love him he goes he goes look
at this sick view of downtown l.a
you can barely see like one
building this this is the new
college living in a content house
yeah yeah but my differences in college
my house was worth
two hundred thousand dollars maybe yeah
it's five guys packed in there it was
tiny
yeah yeah this is yeah this is these
guys are actually living like it's not
that this isn't a nice house
no it's just funny that you that this is
a five million dollar house and again
it's like this is the most basic [ __ ]
ikea destination
possibilities like why they got him on
like [ __ ]
plywood because they all do that they
all just go bare minimum welcome to
phase clan and they just put a
ten like five cinder blocks on each side
and like a piece of drywall across the
top and they're like that's your gamer
desk
maybe one day you'll get a light if you
work hard enough if you work hard enough
you'll get a light
keep getting those dubs homie we got you
a phase sleeping bag how about that
that'd be so funny you came in to work
at face
very very first day and they're like all
right here's your standing desk
and that's it
uh oh no wait wait hold on here's a
little neon light
uh yeah we'll figure out how to get the
window to open
it's kind of locked shut right now yeah
i know it's kind of a sweat box in here
but
we'll figure out the ventilation you
keep grinding and we're going to
we'll get you a webcam so you can do a
face cam win a couple of those
tournaments and we'll get you some ac
huh get your little little fan and put
it on the desk how'd you like that huh
we made sure to get a long 10 foot piece
of you know
piece of drywall so you got some space
on here yeah that makes some room
because
your your fortnite partner's going to be
playing out of here too yeah you're
sharing rooms
yeah yeah yeah and so uh yeah you're
going to want to win on fridays you guys
can get a bunk bed exactly
because this is both your room actually
who knows i mean dream big one day you
guys could have a bean bag
chair as well
[ __ ] you know man
yeah it was cool they gave me a place to
put clothes
so leave a like guys subscribe and
comment so we can get ac
[Laughter]
yeah dude the uh
the car knowing that content houses are
the new college is
is just kind of wild yeah like
instead of instead of kids like running
in with the mail being like mom it's
here
it's like a letter from some iv school
they just come running down the stairs
being like
i got in the face mom i got a new phase
and the whole family's crying oh my god
he got in the face
oh my god they call it grandma he's in
face he's in face clan oh my god don't
tell your grandfather
he was a hundred thieves alum yeah you
should have went hundred thieves but i
guess i could have
it's okay with me
[Laughter]
hey
nuke squad proud mom of a phase nuke
squad proud mom of face
nuclear missile
[Laughter]
and then she has this sticker dildo she
has that sticker on like a prada bag
my son's in face clan yeah
he just graduated from faze clan is
there any way you can move this
appointment up my son's in phase clan
and i'm gonna miss his tournament
my mom i got into the bro-bro house
[Laughter]
i'm in the bro-bro house i got into the
house oh no here we go
mom just accepted me
oh my god honey that's
i'm looking to play some among us with
my boys
dude do you know meat canyon i don't
know how the [ __ ] i just discovered oh
man
his animation is crazy can you can you
pull up the i want to play among us with
my boys
video that's like a it's like someone
clipped it out it has to be one of the
funniest things
like it hit me so hard in the funny bone
during the mr beast episode easter beast
mystery
he's like man i wish i was terminally
ill i drive a ford focus
this is just bang that dude
play loudly
what the um luke that's the opposite
that's completely silent
[Laughter]
play among us with my boys
with my boys nope
nope your boy drives a for focus
[ __ ] did you see that episode um the
whole thing yeah
maybe like i have no memory
uh did you have you seen the minecraft
one no with the kid
no i feel like we should just watch that
it's so good is it not so good i know
all these are hysterical
how long is the minecraft one we can't
just that one right
his video is content bro that can't just
be a podcast just
watching some other dudes videos it's
too good it's too good
let's just shout out the video you got
and you guys go watch it what's it
called the
the the passion passion of the craft
[ __ ] it's so funny you can't just rip
his content wholesale
all right fine all right fine
you